I want to find a man who will know
better than me so whatever he says but
that's hard because now I need to find
someone who's going to be smart enough
to know where we need to live for
tyrannical purposes tax purposes all of
it where we're going to raise children I
don't know and I interviewed somebody
and he said women are children right you
know what yeah like I don't know I can't
make that adult decision I've made an
adult decision to be here this is good
for me right now in this country but
long time I don't know so I have to find
someone who I can trust enough to say
Leia we're living there I'll be like
okay thank God you chose because I just
I I don't know